la seule reviennent peu à peu aux
régimes précédents les contacts directs
personnels se rétablisse et peut-être
que les projets qui avaient été écartés
un moment peuvent reprendre et il me
semble très important d'avoir cette
discussion en direct avec les
représentants des milieux d'affaires
pour parler un petit peu de nos projets
d'avenir et parler de nos projets en
commun vrai que les régions et comme
vous avez vu aujourd'hui nous avons
parlé du travail systématique que à
faire au niveau des investissements
et là nous avons comme au présent comme
objectif précis de travailler dans le
milieu des nouvelles technologies mettre
en place des sites de production de
façon plus
les opérationnels que certains pays qui
sont nos concurrents nos partenaires
d'autant plus que l'année qui viennent
qui vient nous avons l'intention
d'investir beaucoup plus dans les
transports dans les communications dans
le tourisme et des projets de haute
technologie dans la santé publique ainsi
que d'autres secteurs qui vaut 10 de la
population
hélas la russie ouvre un certain nombre
d'opportunités pour les initiatives
privées dans ce que je vous propose
aujourd'hui c'est qu'on parle
conformément à la tradition que nous
discutions que nous échangions sur les
questions qui vous préoccupent qui
procure aux entreprises et qui sont
déterminants pour les investissements
comme d'habitude je voudrais entendre
quelles sont vos impressions vos
propositions en matière de d'instruments
d'encouragement à l'initiative
économique en fonction des tendances
actuelles de l'économie de l'évolution
du marché de l'emploi et bref de toutes
les tendances qui vous être déterminante
pour les la période à venir
merci messieurs possible pour cette
occasion de nous réunir en format
traditionnel ou plutôt un format hybride
j'ai dit à nos collègues aujourd'hui il
n'y aurait pas de 10 mais comment mais
je pense qu'ils peuvent trouver ou 10
mais parce que c'est comme ça la ville
de saint pétersbourg
ici vous pouvez voir les représentants
des milieux d'affaires étrangers qui
sont déjà connus en russie qui ont
réalisé de nombreux projets en russie et
participent de manière systémique forum
international de saint pétersbourg
il ya aussi de nouveaux participants
certains d'entre eux sont les nouveaux
dirigeants des entreprises qui sont
présentes
depuis longtemps sur le marché russe il
ya aussi ceux qui envisagent de rentrer
sur le marché
nous avons analysé les sujets qui était
intéressant pour nos collègues et il
s'avère que les questions que vous avez
abordé aujourd'hui lors de la session
plénière sont les plus intéressantes il
s'agit notamment de l'économie verte du
développement durable de la
modernisation technologique
parce que la pandémie a notamment à
accélérer cette transformation numérique
il s'agit également des problèmes de
prévisibilité de règlement vous avez
évoqué aujourd'hui au nombre de 1 cas
concrets en répondant à des questions et
il s'avère que les règles de jeu doivent
être prévisible une sont pas modifiées
de manière considérable au cours des
sessions nous avons beaucoup parlé des
changements de modification des normes
dans le btp nous pouvons maintenant men
et les travaux plus rapidement il y a
des moyens et nos collègues son coin et
je tiens à donner la parole à rolande
bush le président et le pdg de siemens
c'est l'entreprise
qui est très connue notamment en russie
c'est un partenaire important et surtout
dans la solution des problèmes que vous
avez évoqué notamment les technologies
les l'écologie le climat et cetera